What would happen if SCP-173, the Sculpture,
was put inside SCP-914, the Clockworks?
Rough: 173 would likely be reduced
to a pile of dust and rubble.
Though it’d likely rebuild itself afterward.
Coarse: We imagine this would split
173 into three parts - Head, Torso,
and butt/legs. Once again, it wouldn’t
take long for him to return afterward.
1:1: We speculate that it’d turn
into SCP-650, the Startling Statue.
Fine: This could lead to a larger, faster SCP-173,
capable of snapping more necks when eyes
aren’t on it, which 173 would very much enjoy.
Very Fine: Perhaps this would lead to an
SCP-173 the size of the Statue of Liberty,
capable of snapping skyscrapers and stomping
neighborhoods when nobody is looking at it.